en una parrillada para celebrar el final
de la temporada de fútbol se sirvieron
mil 354 salchichas redondea el número de
salchichas a la decena más cercana vamos
a reescribir la cantidad mil 354
recordemos nuestros lugares este es el
lugar de las unidades ese es el de las
decenas este es el de las centenas y
este es el de los millares y nos piden
redondear el número de salchichas a la
decena más cercana en este momento
tenemos cinco decenas pero para el
redondeo necesitamos ver la cantidad que
se encuentra en el lugar que está a la
derecha de esta posición vemos las
unidades y nos encontramos que hay un 4
que es menor que 5 por lo que vamos a
redondear abajo esto es menor que 5 así
que redondeamos hacia abajo lo que nos
da exactamente 5 decenas o 1350 hemos
redondeado a la decena más cercana 1350
salchichas hagamos otro problema nos
dicen que la asistencia al juego local
de básquetbol fue
ocho mil 643 personas redondea la
asistencia a la centena más cercana y
como siempre pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo por su cuenta reescribimos
la cantidad que es de ocho mil 643
queremos redondear a la centena más
cercana por lo que observamos el número
que se encuentra a la derecha de este
lugar y nos preguntamos si este número
es menor que 5 si es menor que 5
entonces vamos a redondear hacia abajo
si hubiera sido mayor o igual que 5
entonces hubiéramos redondeado hacia
arriba pero esto es menor que 5 lo
redondeamos abajo lo que nos da 8.600 lo
redondeamos a la centena más cercana que
nos dieron 8 mil 600 personas resolvamos
otro problema la ciudad de pueblo lindo
tiene 87 mil 388 residentes redondea el
número de personas que viven en pueblo
lindo al millar más cercano tenemos 87
mil 388 personas y nos piden redondear
más cercano nuevamente nos fijamos en el
número que está a la derecha de esta
posición y vemos si es menor o igual a 5
en efecto tres es menor que cinco por lo
que vamos a redondear abajo que nos da
87 mil que es el millar más cercano y ya
que todos estos ejemplos resultaron en
un redondeo hacia abajo permítanme
mostrarles qué pasaría si tuviéramos
otra cantidad por ejemplo si hubiéramos
tenido 87 mil 588 nuevamente nos piden
redondear al millar más cercano nos
fijamos en el número que está a la
derecha de esta posición y en este caso
vemos que es 5 y en el caso de que sea
mayor o igual a 5 redondeamos el millar
hacia arriba lo que nos da 88 mil en
este caso así que siempre vamos a
observar el número que está un lugar a
la derecha de la posición que nos
interesa redondear si ese número es
menor que 5 vamos a redondear abajo y si
es mayor o igual a 5 entonces vamos a
redondear arriba